okay
live
good evening and welcome to our spatial
options consultation webinar uh my
name's daniel and i'm team leader for
rochester district council strategic
planning team
this webinar is being streamed online
this evening and will be made available
to be watched back at a later time
including by those unable to watch this
evening
so the consultat well the webinar this
evening has three main purposes
uh these are to explain
what relationship district council is
consulting on and why
to explain how interested people can
find out more information and respond to
the consultation and finally to respond
to some of the more frequently asked
questions about the consultation
including those made for the dedicated
question form that was created for this
webinar
so what is the local plan and why does
it matter so the spatial options
consultation that the council has
recently launched and that this webinar
relates to forms part of a wider process
for preparing a new local plan for
rochford district
every district council in the country is
expected to prepare a local plan for
their area
so look local plans are written
documents they contain long-term visions
and strategies and they also contain a
wide range of policies that planning
decisions are made against these
policies relate to a wide range of
issues big and small so new housing
estates and neighbours extensions will
all be related back to these policies
fundamentally local plans also set out
what land can be used for and where new
housing and economic developments will
be allowed
so a local plan is prepared over many
years rochester district council has
been preparing its new local plan since
2015 and previously consulted in 2018 on
a document called the issues and options
document
the consultation that this webinar
relates to is the second of an expected
four stages of the new local plan just
as a reminder this consultation is known
as the spatial options consultation
we are relatively early stage in
preparing our local plan
and we expect to consult two more times
both in early 2020 and then in 2023 at
each stage of consultation the details
within the consultation document are
more specific about what the local plan
is likely to contain
in 2023 we hope to arrive at a final
local plan ready to be submitted to a
government inspector
it's important to get into get involved
at this stage of the consultation to
make sure that your views are taken into
account when decisions are made on that
final local plan
so what does the spatial options
document contain
so this facial options document itself
has three main sections document covers
a wide range of issues that all
contribute to a sustainable future for
district so those three main parts
include options for the overall vision
and strategy for the new local plan so
new local plans are long term documents
set up over 15 to 20 years and they need
a vision and a strategy to bind together
all of the contents
secondly uh it contains options for how
the new local plan could address a wide
range of key issues such as housing
transport heritage community facilities
open spaces and the economy
lastly the consultation document sets
out specific options for how the new
local plan could address individual
towns and villages that includes local
villages for each settlement local
visions for each settlement excuse me
potential areas that could be developed
and protected
[Music]
so what is public feedback being sought
on
it's important to emphasize the local
plan is still at an early stage and only
sets out options at this time
therefore all of the matters contained
within the conservation document are not
finally decided and they are just
options however responses to
consultations such as this is important
to imply influence which of the options
ultimately are selected we recognize
that not every option presented in the
document is equally suitable it's
important that public feedback is made
into the process to understand which
options could work
i would also emphasize at this stage
that the consultation has recently been
extended and now closes at 5 pm on
wednesday 22nd of september
so how can you access the consultation
so there are three main ways you can
access and respond to the consultation
these are using the online consultation
portal detail by downloading a copy of
the consultation document and responding
by email or letter or finally by viewing
a physical copy of the consultation
document in local libraries and council
offices responding by email or letter
more information on how to respond is
set out in some of the following slides
so firstly the information we're going
to provide is how you might want to use
the online consultation portal
so the online consultation portal is
available at rochford.oc2.uk
you can follow that link to find out
more information on the consultation
you can see on your screen now there is
a red circled link to the new local plan
spatial options document 2021
this is the link you should click if you
want to find out more about the
consultation and read through the
consultation document
clicking on that link will display the
page shown here
so
you're then able to navigate through the
consultation document in one of two ways
you can either select the green link
shown on the screen which will take you
to specific parts of the document or
even specific questions
alternatively you can scroll through the
entire text clicking the next chapter
button at the bottom of each page to
move through each section
so throughout the document there are a
number of questions so these questions
are where your feedback can be made to
the consultation
using the online consultation portal
it's important to look out for these
purple boxes that contain q and then a
number indicating the question number
they also have a blue speech bubble next
to them
to leave a comment you can click the
speech bubble icon to the left of the
question box this will present a menu
within the question box where you can
input your comments please note you may
need to first follow a prompt to log in
or make a profile to leave a comment
this is because we are unable by law to
accept anonymous comments it should show
what is currently on screen giving you
an option to support object or comment
and then leave further information in a
free form text box
so an alternative way of accessing the
consultation is by downloading a copy of
the document and responding by email or
by letter
so again the link that you would need to
follow to access a downloadable copy of
the document is rochford.oc2.uk
at this time you would need to click the
black bar indicated on the screen which
says spatial options downloadable copies
and topic papers
if you click on that black bar you will
be presented with this screen
this will display a number of links
where you can download copies of the
consultation document
please note the version labeled simple
may be more appropriate for printing and
mobile devices however the content and
questions within these copies is
identical to that on the consultation
portal
however if you access conversation in
this way by downloading a copy to your
own computer you will need to submit
your comments manually either by email
to spatial options at rochford.gov
or by post to council offices south
street rochford
ss41bw details are on the screen and
also on our website
so the last way that you can access a
copy of the consultation is by viewing a
physical copy in local libraries or
council offices
these are available when open however
you may want to check opening times as
these may now be different uh in the
covid times paper response forms have
also been deposited at these locations
and you may find it easier to make your
responses using the paper response forms
if you do choose to access the
constellation using this method you can
respond by either emailing again any
comments you have to spatial options at
rochefort.gov uk
or by posting any comments you have to
council offices south street rochford
ss41bw
this information is again on our website
should you need it at a later date there
is also a sheet available in those
locations where the documents are
sending out more information about how
to respond and send in comments
so other information relevant to the
consultation so beyond just the
consultation document the council has
also made available a number of
background documents that may be
interesting to people who are looking
into more information about consultation
so there are three main types of
background document the council has made
available as part of this process these
are the evidence base which are
technical studies relating to certain
issues to do with the local plan this
might include a greenbelt study a
landscape study
land availability study and other
technical studies some of these
documents are prepared by the council
but many are prepared by expert
consultants
secondly we have published a number of
topic papers these are non-technical
summary documents explaining how the
council's new local plan relates back to
key issues such as housing or transport
or the environment
finally there is the interactive map
so the interactive map which some people
may have already used basically shows
many of the spatial issues set out in
the consultation documents such as
pieces of land that have been put
forward to be considered for development
as well as other constraints such as
open spaces town centres etc
this can be accessed
using um a link that is published on our
website and it's also worth saying at
this point that a separate guide to the
interactive map has been made available
on the council's website using the link
now on the screen it can also be found
on the main consultation web
page the uh of the consultation
so the next section of the webinar um
is about frequently asked questions
so we created a form where people were
able to submit questions that they
wanted the council to answer during this
session
we have also received a number of
frequently asked questions when doing uh
recent events as well as through phone
calls and emails and we are attempting
to respond to as many of those today as
we can
what i would emphasize at this point is
um
some questions have been generalized
because they've been answered many times
in many different forms so to avoid
repetition we have grouped together
questions where the same response
applies to multiple questions therefore
if you don't see the exact question that
you asked it may be that it is responded
to in in the form of another question
similarly some questions did come in uh
relatively late in the process um
i.e today or just before this webinar so
unfortunately it has not been possible
to include those in this presentation
however what i would emphasize is the
council is committed to providing
written responses to all of these
questions on the website
as soon as possible therefore even if
your question is not included in those
covered in this webinar it will be
receive a written response on the
council's website as soon as possible
and that will again be linked from the
main consultation webpage on the
council's website
so the first question
uh that we've sought to answer in this
section is why do we have to plan for
new development so one of the key roles
of the local plan is obviously to plan
for new development and that might be in
the form of allocating areas of land in
the district where new housing or
economic development will be considered
acceptable so local plans such as the
one being prepared by rochester council
need to be prepared within both
government policy and legislation and in
order to be approved local plans need to
pass certain tests set by government so
one of these tests requires local plans
to meet the needs of an area unless
there are compelling reasons not to do
so
so the starting point for working out
how much development might be needed in
an area is a government methodology for
housing need so for rochford this
methodology results in a figure of
around 360 homes per year which works
out at around 7 200 homes over the next
20 years
however it's worth emphasizing that many
of these homes are already being planned
for including existing development sites
such as those in the west of raleigh or
in holbridge or at hall road in rochford
when totaling all of the existing sites
together
we expect that we could deliver around
four to four to four and a half thousand
homes on these existing sites so
compared to a need of around seven
thousand two hundred that might leave
anywhere in the region of two thousand
three and a half thousand yet to be
planned for over the next twenty years
so through the local plan the council
will need to consider how much
development should be planned for as
well as uh to plan for other forms of
development such as new jobs and
services there's no guarantee at this
stage about how much development will
ultimately result in the local plan
however we have to go through this
process which i reiterate again we are a
relatively early stage of to work out
how much of our development needs can be
sustainably met in the area
so the second question that we have been
asked in this section is what will the
council's overall strategy be for new
development
so in the spatial options consultation
document there are four main options set
out for how development could be
distributed
so these are option one to focus
development within existing urban areas
option two to extend existing towns and
villages
option three to focus development in one
large area of more than one and a half
thousand houses or option four to strike
a combination of the other three options
it is however extremely important to
emphasize that no matter which of these
options is selected government and
council policy is clear that brownfield
contaminated and vacant sites will need
to be used before considering any green
filled sites
therefore the spatial options
consultation document provides detailed
information on each of these four
options with an opportunity for you to
tell us which of these strategies you
would pick or indeed if you think there
is an alternative strategy that we have
missed
so the next question that we've been
asked is where will new development be
located so again it's important to
emphasize at this stage that no
decisions have been made about where new
development will be located conservation
document refers to a number of what
would have been called promoted sites so
these are areas of land where the
landowner or developers ask the council
to consider when preparing it with its
local plan
an initial assessment of all of these
sites is available by using the
interactive map or on the consultation
website however i would emphasize this
assessment is initial and more robust
and technical assessments will be needed
before decisions are made about whether
any of these sites should be developed
therefore whilst no decisions have
currently been made on future
development locations you can help to
ensure the decisions that are made about
sites are the right ones by responding
to the consultation by telling us which
sites you think could be developed which
sites you think shouldn't be developed
and if certain sites were to be
developed what type of infrastructure or
protections would be needed to make that
sustainable
so the next question that we have
received is
what does the council mean when it says
promoted site and this question might be
particularly important in the context of
our interactive map which shows many of
these promoted sites in a blue color on
that map
typically with a reference beginning cfs
so
you may have seen land being referred to
as a promoted site um
through their local plans all councils
need to consider what land might be
available to use for different purposes
such as housing or economic development
councils therefore often issue what is
called call for sites where developers
and landowners can put forward land that
they want the council to consider for
development
so there's no uh sifting process at this
stage about what types of site can be
put forward but the council is duty
bound to consider all of the sites that
are being put forward
some of these sites are clearly never
going to be suitable and may be subject
to major constraints such as flood risk
so promoted sites in the consultation
document are all of the areas of land
that were received by the council
through this call for science process
these promoter sites are shown as blue
shapes on our interactive map and on
maps within the document
so it's important to emphasize again
that the inclusion of a promoted site in
the document does not mean it will be
developed only a small fraction of the
sites put forward would ever be needed
even if the council was to meet its
development needs in full and like i
said earlier many of the sites have been
put forward would have significant
constraints that would prevent them from
ever being developed
so the next question that we have been
asked is what are the risks of not
planning for new development
so uh
one of the reasons that we're obviously
doing this is to make sure that the
council's position is is solid in in
terms of uh retaining control over where
uh new development might be located
and so
it's important to emphasize that the
planning system does allow developers to
appeal directly to a government
inspector if a planning application is
refused by the council
it may therefore be possible for
developers to get permission for a
development through the appeal process
if they can demonstrate that
insufficient homes are being built in an
area to meet needs
therefore it's important the council
takes a proactive approach through its
local plans considering how those homes
could be developed and only concludes
that the homes could not be developed if
it has compelling evidence
there are also other risks to not
planning for new development firstly not
building enough housing in an area does
contribute to that housing becoming
increasingly unaffordable particularly
for first-time buyers and this has led
to increases in the number of younger
people living at home for far longer
than they'd like or leaving the district
entirely to find a new home
that same situation also exists for many
businesses so if not enough business
premises or not high quality business
premises are planned for there is a risk
that none of the existing premises meet
the needs of our businesses as they grow
and therefore they choose to relocate in
other areas potentially losing
jobs or potential jobs that could be
created if they had places to grow into
so the next question that has been asked
is
how is infrastructure capacity taken
into account when decisions are made
so this autumn the council will prepare
a key document for the new local plan
which is called the infrastructure
delivery plan so this document will
allow the council to consider how
potential locations for new development
relate to infrastructure capacity issues
and opportunities so one of the
recurring themes when we've gone out and
had conversations with people in the
streets is obviously concerns around the
capacity of existing roads existing
schools gp surgeries etc so when
decisions are made about where new
development may be located capacity of
all of that type of infrastructure is
going to be given significant weight
that infrastructure delivery plan will
be a formal process for understanding
capacity of that new infrastructure as
well as potentially any opportunities
there may be to create new
infrastructure
or expand existing provision
that study will consider a lot of those
information and will feed into the next
stage in the preparation the local plan
which is called the preferred options so
before a preferred list of development
sites is developed by the council we
will have developed a detailed
understanding of infrastructure capacity
issues and opportunities
so it is also worth re-emphasizing at
this stage the council works closely
with those infrastructure providers
including essex county council and the
nhs as well as utility providers to
ensure that any infrastructure
that is required for new development can
be expanded to support population growth
and the council will be working with
those organizations to try and ensure
that their investment programs do
deliver uh capacity improvements that
can support any of the growth that goes
into this new local plan it may also be
possible to attract external funding
from government
however again more information is likely
to be needed about
where and how new development could be
located
so a similar question which is will the
new local plan deliver new
infrastructure
so when developers build new homes or
business premises they are required to
make financial contributions towards
local infrastructure so you may
sometimes hear these are these
contributions referred to as section 106
contributions which is named after the
legal agreements that these
contributions are enshrined in
so
and in general the larger a development
is the larger the financial
contributions will be so it's important
we get the strategy of our new local
plan right to make sure we can get uh
the most most uh bang for our buck in
terms of new infrastructure so the
decisions about how much development
should be located in certain areas and
where it should be located is absolutely
fundamental to understanding what new
infrastructure may be possible
so an overview of how those different
strategy options relate back to
potential infrastructure opportunities
is set out in the consultation document
in the strategy options section
there are also information in there
about the general assumptions that we
use about the size of new developments
that might need to fund different types
of infrastructure this is all of course
all predicated on the ability for
development to fund this infrastructure
and as i said on the previous slide it
may be possible to attract funding
directly from the infrastructure
organizations or government to also help
deliver more transformational
infrastructure improvements
so the next question that we have been
asked is
how can we be sure that infrastructure
will be delivered first
so
one of the
main challenges in planning is that
often the infrastructure that is being
funded by development
isn't delivered at the early stages of
the development and may be delivered
quite late on in the development's
lifespan so the council will need to
make a concerted effort through its new
local plan to make sure that
infrastructure is put in place at the
earliest stages of any new development
at this stage of the process it's not
possible to identify specific projects
or sites for infrastructure as we
require an understanding of where
development may be suitable if that
development is required to fund the
infrastructure so for example a site
being identified for new infrastructure
in rayleigh will not work if the funding
for it is being created from a
development in great wakering and by law
the funding made available for
infrastructure needs to be spent to
service the area that new development is
located
so beyond direct funding from
developments the council will also need
to work with cancer council the nhs
central government and utility companies
to ensure that investment plans align
with our own local plan
so the next question is
why is the consultation only six weeks
long
so government regulations require
consultations or local plans to be at
least six weeks in length so we have
recognized that during the summer
holidays it may be difficult for people
to get back or they may not have the
time to develop a detailed response to
consultation therefore we have extended
the consultation deadline by two weeks
so it now results in an eight-week
consultation so the new closing date for
the consultation as said on a previous
slide is wednesday the 22nd of september
and this will be kept under review to
make sure that as many people are able
to respond as possible
so the next question that has been asked
is
has the council already carried out
a local needs survey to establish
requirements for housing in the next
plan period and if so at what stage will
sites suitable for further housing be
identified so we'll just iterate that a
plan period basically refers to the life
of a new local plan so a 15 20 year
period
um
so as touched on earlier in the
presentation councils are expected to
plan for their development needs through
their local plan
the starting point for knowing how much
to plan for is a government methodology
and this government methodology has
previously stated suggests around 360
homes need to be built each year to meet
rockford's needs that works out around 7
200 homes over 20 years
so it's worth saying at this point as
well that previous evidence that the
council prepared itself back in 2017
calculated a figure of around 330 to 360
homes a year which is obviously broadly
similar to that number
so the current consultation does set out
options for how those needs could be met
so those strategy options are referred
to before
but this stage no specific locations of
all sites have been selected future
stages of consultation will provide more
detail as this emerges just as a
reminder
we hope to consult again in the next
spring and then finally again in 2023
and each of those consultations will
contain more detailed information about
what the council
suggests should be done for its new
local plan so the next consultation will
contain far more information about the
strategy and the sites the council
thinks the new local plan should contain
so the next uh
question that has been asked is what was
the level of interest in the self book
register
so for anybody who isn't aware of the
self build register it was introduced by
government for individuals and
households to register an interest in
building their own home
and typically what this requires is a
serviced plot i.e a piece of land that
already has connections to utilities
that somebody can come along and design
and build their own home
so the register was introduced in 2016
and currently has 83 individuals
registered to it which is a relatively
significant number
at this stage however no specific sites
have been identified for self-filled
projects however options are set out in
the consultation document about how this
could be done so it may be that specific
areas of land could be specifically
allocated for self-built plots only so
they could be divided up and sold off by
the landowner to individual houses uh
who then come forward and design their
own home the advantage of something like
that is obviously then it's a very
direct way of making sure local people
can get
on the housing register because there's
a bit more control about who buys the
homes uh alternatively it could be that
on any larger housing sites that that
may be built a certain percentage of the
homes need to be made available for
self-built so there are options set out
in the consultation document and these
are set out in the housing for all
section in that document
so
the next question that has been asked is
why has the council not done a transport
assessment before asking the public to
comment on the proposed sites for future
development how can the residents of
rochester district be expected to give a
worthwhile response without knowing what
road improvements are being considered
to go along with the proposed siting of
the additional housing
so i would emphasize that work on a
transport assessment is currently
underway and we'll consider how
different options would impact on key
junctions by options again i mean
different strategies or different sites
of different developments uh
alternatives
so key part of any transport assessment
would be identifying any improvements
that would need to be delivered to make
any new housing sustainable
so that assessment is still underway
um the reason why it hasn't been
published before this consultation is
that where development is expected to
fund improvements to the road network
there needs to be a rough understanding
of where that development could go
so similar to the previous example we
gave road improvements in rayleigh could
not be delivered if the funding was to
come from developments in great wakering
therefore to understand where it may be
possible to fund those improvements
through development we do need to have a
rough a rough idea about where that new
development could be located
but nevertheless the transport
assessment will be a public document and
it will be published in due course
before the next round of consultation
and individuals and residents will be
able to review that information and make
any comments that they feel necessary
so the next question that we have
received was
are you going ahead with the old plan of
a new road from the a130 through to
shuberi
so similar to the previous response a
transport assessment is currently
planned and that would need to identify
any potential mitigation or new options
that may be required to help
support any new housing or other
development however opportunities for
specific road improvements such as new
routes um whilst they will be considered
where justified and where where fundable
um
they would still need to be given an
appropriate weight to the likelihood of
getting funding and that wider
environmental impact and it is worth
saying obviously um transformational
road improvements would likely require a
significant amount of funding to be
delivered um and new road routes that
the difficulty may be that um that it
then then makes uh significant amounts
of land therefore uh more sustainable
for development and therefore maybe
makes uh areas that are currently quite
rural uh suddenly very suitable um for
for housing just from a road perspective
so there is a balance and the transport
assessment's the appropriate mechanism
to consider those issues
so the next question that we have
is
will rochefort council strive to protect
greenbelt and agricultural land in light
of the ongoing global crisis of global
warming and climate change so i would
reiterate again that national and
council policy is clear that brownfield
contaminated and vacant sites will need
to be developed prior to any greenfield
sites being selected
so in line with national policy
greenbelt land would only be considered
for development in exceptional
circumstances so it really is a case of
exhausting those brownfield contaminated
and vacant sites before
looking at greenbelt land and obviously
significant weight will be given to the
need to protect agricultural land and
there is some information in the
consultation document and some of the
supporting materials about different
areas of agricultural land quality in
the district
and clearly there are areas that are
used for light agriculture that are of
less value than areas that are used for
quite heavy agriculture and those types
of issues will need to be taken into
account
so the next question that we have
received is
will rochelle council protect the
heritage and rural village field of
great wakering and other villages or
will it allow to become will it allow it
to become an extension of shubiness
so i would just reiterate that one of
the key uh points of greenbelt policy so
all the undeveloped land in in rockford
outside the main settlement is generally
protected by a government policy called
greenbelt that some listeners may have
heard of previously but one of the main
purposes of greenbelt is to avoid
neighbouring towns villages from merging
into one another
therefore the need to avoid that merging
between towns and villages will be a key
consideration in deciding where any new
development should be located
so the next question that we have
received is
will land in fanbridge such as elsmere
road be included as most plots are
infill so i would just reiterate again
at this stage that no decisions have
been made about which of you know if any
of the sites should be developed
interested parties can advise of the
land that they think should be developed
however at this stage we have not come
to any formal decisions or conclusions
about any of those individual sites so
it's not possible to to
to know whether or not any particular
site is likely to be selected or not at
this stage
the next question we have received is
can the single trunk road uh
ied a127
uh and nhs hospital um presumably south
end hospital cope with a 30 increase in
loading bearing in mind both were
defined as at or near capacity in 2011.
so similar to the answer to a previous
question work on a transport assessment
is currently underway and we'll consider
how different options would impact on
key junctions there also exists an a127
task force which is looking at long-term
options to improve the capacity and flow
of the a127 more information on that is
available online under a127 taskforce
again a key part of any transport
assessment would be identifying any
improvements that are needed to support
any new development
and ultimately decisions will not be
allowed on developments that would cause
unacceptable harm to the traffic network
and less mitigation can be secured
i would also emphasize the council work
closely with the nhs and developments
are required to contribute financially
to the nhs to allow local facilities to
be expanded so this includes primary
care uh to south bend hospital how that
money is actually spent though is a
responsibility for the local health
trusts
so the next question that we have is
why is road infrastructure not at the
top of the list to be tackled first
so again road infrastructure is a key
consideration in any future decisions
about the new local plan strategy so
that transport assessment i mentioned
previously we will consider the impact
of attention to development on traffic
flows on key roads and junctions and we
will be working with business county
council to try to make sure that
investments can be made to the road
network to make sure that it is as
sustainable as possible
clearly if developments are going to
have an unacceptable impact on the road
network that can't be mitigated they are
unlikely to be selected as part of the
new local plan
so the next question is will the
boundaries of the roach valley be taken
into consideration so
the boundaries of the upper roach valley
special landscape area which is an area
of broad land
from around southeast rayleigh
under to the south of of hockley and out
towards
rochford in the east
is an identified constraint it's an area
that's identified as being of importance
for
landscaping it's also an area that's
identified as a kind of green lung for
the district so all of that those
qualities will be taken into account
when considering potential sites for
development there is a landscape
character assessment that the council
has had prepared
which is available on the consultation
website and that again reiterates the
importance of that area for its
landscape qualities
so the next question is
will you be preventing the use of
already dwindling green spaces in the
district for building
so green spaces in the sense of parks
and open spaces are not currently being
considered for development as part of
the new local plan
in fact the consultation document
identifies a whole wide range of these
open spaces both public open spaces
private open spaces and
recommends them for
protection there's also a specific
policy
looked at in the consultation document
known as local green space and those are
green spaces that are particularly
important to local communities
and through local plans councils can
identify local green spaces that are
important to the local communities and
afford them the same strength of
protection from development as greenbelt
land
so for green space is in a wider sense
it is worth reiterating again that
council and government policy is very
clear that brownfield and vacant sites
need to be developed prior to
considering greenfield sites for
development
so the next question that we received
was
what steps are the council planning to
address
uh planning to address housing in this
district for the hidden homeless those
sofa surfing and adults forced to live
with parents as they have low wages and
the price to rent slash buy is too high
so i would advise that around a third of
home build on larger sites are made
available for affordable housing and the
council has 100 nomination rights on the
initial way for these properties and a
local eligibility test
it is however also working out that
we're pointing out that a new type of
affordable housing has recently been
introduced by government and this is
called first homes this is specifically
a type of affordable housing that is
made available to first-time buyers and
that's made available to first-time
buyers in perpetuity so if you as a
first-time buyer were to buy that house
you would then need to sell it to
another first-time buyer and maintain a
percentage discount for our in
perpetuity
uh so through the local plan the council
can obviously try to make sure as much
of those affordable homes are developed
as possible uh and make sure that policy
requirement on
new development sites uh pushes that
percentage uh as high as it can go so at
the moment like i said around a third
that it may be possible to require 40 or
even higher than 40
of homes to be different types of
affordable tenure and that obviously
includes those first homes but also
social housing uh affordable rent and
other types of affordable housing
uh it's also probably worth pointing out
that generally trying to address housing
issues is also important and comes back
to some of those strategy issues
mentioned earlier in the presentation
about how housing need could be
addressed in a more general sense
so the next question that has been asked
is
what provisions do the council have to
accommodate the disabled members of our
society so access to some areas are
restricted for wheelchair users woodland
walks pavements and roads
vehicles cars lorries vans use the
pavements as parking and cyclists use
them as their very own road as they feel
the actual roads are too dangerous for
them making it hazardous for those with
visual impairment severe visual
impairment wheelchairs etc
so the council can create policies in
its new local plan that require
developments to be built to suitable
standards of accessibility
it is more challenging to retrofit
existing
services and existing areas um but it
may be possible for the new local plan
to help fund accessibility improvements
in certain locations so development's
being built in a village may be able to
make contributions to improve the
accessibility of local parks or local
woodland local pavements etc as part of
its kind of community contribution
through um through section 106's which i
mentioned earlier uh also currently
three percent of homes the largest sites
are required to be built to full
wheelchair accessibility standards again
through the new local plan it may be
possible to review this and revise this
figure upwards to make sure more homes
that are being built on development
sites are ready made for those with uh
movement impairment
or those using wheelchairs
so the next uh the next question we have
received is
how many applicants are currently on
rdc's housing waiting list and what
percentage of the proposed additional
housing will be social or affordable
housing
so i can advise there are currently
around 980 individuals on the council's
housing register
and as previously stated the council's
current policies require around a third
of new homes on larger sites to be one
of those affordable tenures such as
first homes affordable rent social
housing etc so the current split of
affordable housing that comes out of
that third is around 80 affordable rent
and about 20 shared ownership so shared
ownership is a housing model where an
individual can buy a percentage of a
house and then rent the remaining
percentage uh from a housing association
in some cases they may be able to
ultimately buy the housing association
stake in other cases
they would rent in perpetuity and move
uh potentially move to an alternative
house at a certain point
so ultimately this policy can be
reviewed and the requirements um around
affordable housing could be increased so
that could include both the number of
affordable homes expected on new
developments so that 33 or 35 figure
could be increased to 40 or uh even
higher percentage uh and also that's
split um of different types of
affordable housing could also be
reviewed um to make sure that it's an
appropriate mix of affordable housing to
meet the needs of local people there is
also an opportunity to
to be more clear about the types of
housing in terms of size that should be
provided alongside affordable housing
provision
um so just um
just to answer the second part of the
question what percentage of the proposed
additional housing will be social
affordable housing well based on the
current policy you might expect a third
of those new homes to be affordable um
however obviously as i've said it may be
a higher figure ultimately
so the next question we've received is
why have sites identified as having an
adverse impact on heritage been included
within the promoted sites
so it's worth saying again that the
consultation document includes all of
the sites that landowners have asked us
to consider so as i said in the answer
to a previous question the council
issued what's known as a call for sites
and this call for sites gave landowners
and developers the opportunity to
formally ask the council to consider
particular pieces of land when it was
putting forward its
local plan
so at this stage we have not sought to
sift sites from that list and therefore
we we are very aware there will be sites
within uh that list of uh promoted sites
that actually are subject to quite
significant constraints and that's not
just heritage that might also include
blood risk it might also include uh
protected habitats and some more
information um on um the the initial
site appraisal that the council has done
on each of these sites is available if
using the interactive map
mentioned earlier
and you may be able to see through that
scoring process exactly how different
sites have been assessed and it may be
that it that it's quite clear in that
assessment process that actually certain
issues to do with sites have been scored
um
and they show up as a very poor score
against that criteria and again those
types of issues will all be taken into
account when decisions are made about
ultimately which sites need to be
developed
so
the next question that has been asked
is
ultimately where does the demand for new
houses come from
um
so it's worth saying again that national
government policy does require local
councils to plan to meet their housing
needs and the starting point for any
council's local plan is the government
housing need methodology and again that
results in a figure as i've stated
previously of around 360 homes per year
for rochford
but the demand for new houses comes from
various sources um feedback from recent
developments suggests that actually a
majority of the homes being reserved on
new development sites
are being
sold to local people including people
mostly with an ss postcode for example
so rocksford has known issues with
concealed households which are
basically um homes that are
are being lived in by too many people um
and ideally uh you know a subset of
those people would like to move into
their own home
and we have also got known issues in
terms of housing affordability and how
that affects first-time buyers but also
others in the community
so all of those things do contribute to
quite a lot
of
uh housing demand
in the area that's not currently being
met but might not be completely obvious
because those people do have homes it's
just that those homes don't really meet
their needs
however that you know some percentage of
the demand for new housing does come
from people from outside the area
however this is true of all places and
indeed rocha residents are free to also
move to other parts of the area
and and so this is inevitable um
to a large extent
so the next question that has been asked
is uh will the field at the back of
hopley community center owned by odyssey
be allowed to be used as a road for
access to enabling development on the
field belonging to vets farm once its
leased commune center ends so there are
no plans for this as
part of this consultation
so that that isn't being considered as
an option as part of this consultation
so the next question is
how can the council justify the amount
of roadworks on vital roads happening
simultaneously
so it's worth just pointing out the
permission for road works does not fall
under richard rosh council but the issue
has been noted previously
and brought to us county council's
attention um so obviously there's a hope
that that issue will not be repeated um
but it doesn't unfortunately fall under
watchful district council direct direct
implements
so that actually takes us to the end of
the questions that have been submitted
to us there
may be some questions um that haven't
been answered on this session because
they came in after the presentation was
prepared or perhaps because the answer
to them was similar to the answer to
another question so i would just
reiterate at this point that all the
questions submitted through the online
form will receive a written response on
the council's website in due course
and therefore if you haven't seen the
exact question that you want asked
answered in this session it will be
answered
through that written document
so just wrapping up um
there are obviously a few things that um
we would like people to take away from
from this webinar obviously one of which
is is knowing better how to access the
consultation
so
just to reiterate again uh there are
three main ways that people can access
the consultation so those are to use the
online consultation portal which is
available at rochester.oc2.uk
and clicking on that top link that says
new local plan spatial options document
2021
if you go by that way you need to
navigate through the document and find
purple question boxes with blue speech
bubbles next to them if you click on the
blue speech bubble you will be prompted
to leave a comment you may need to log
in or create a profile before you can do
that
the second way of accessing the
consultation is using downloadable
copies that you can download straight to
your computer again to access these you
can go to rochford.oc2.uk
you need to click on the black bar that
says spatial options downloadable copies
and topic papers you need to click from
the two links that that are described as
either the stylized version or the
simple version just to emphasize again
the simple version may display better on
mobile devices or if you plan to print
the document if you access document in
that way you can either submit comments
via email to spatial options at
rochefort.gov
or by post to council offices south
street rochford ss41bw
the third and final way you can access
the consultation is by visiting a local
library or council offices when open and
viewing a physical copy of the document
there will be paper response forms that
you can return to the council
alternatively you can also email
comments in to spatial options at
ruptured.gov dot uk
we'll just emphasize again the point
about the background material so this is
again all linked from rochford.oc2.uk
and you can find information about the
technical studies which are the
evidence-based you can find information
about the topic papers which are the
non-technical summaries you can also
find information about the interactive
map if you have any difficulty using the
interactive map we have published a
guide on the website
uh
written answers to each of the questions
um put forward for the question form as
i said earlier we'll be publishing the
council's website shortly i would just
also emphasize at this point that
you're not obliged to respond to every
question in the consultation document
and you're not obliged to respond
to any of the questions if you feel that
your comments do not neatly fit under
any of those questions you are able just
to email or write in your general views
and then we will manually assign that to
the document if that works easier for
people then that then that is acceptable
too
the consultation closes at 5pm on
wednesday the 22nd of september so again
this is a two-week extension from that
previously advertised
um
and lastly if there are any difficulties
accessing the consultation or further
questions
you can send these to planning.policy at
rockford.gov the uk
so um that is different to the spatial
options at rochford.gov uk email address
which is for
formal comments on the consultation it
would be better to use planning.policy
at rockford.gov uk if you have any
questions about how to access or use the
consultation
so thank you for listening to this
webinar um i would i would thank you for
your time
ultimately the consultation is an
opportunity for people to help shape the
future stages of the local plan we are
still at an early stage and therefore no
decisions have been made about the
contents of that local plan however with
each stage as it progresses obviously
more detail will be published and
ultimately in 2023 we hope to have a
final local plan ready to submit to
government um so it is important people
get involved at every stage um so that
they can be comfortable that the
direction that that local plan heads in
um
takes account of their views
so thank you for your time uh this
evening um
ultimately if you do need to contact our
team please do so before the
consultation deadline um and i hope to
see you very soon thank you